my man when I was growing up I was in a
dance group with this girl and this girl
was the most sexiest hot girl and he
always went on about her and I went out
with I went I met her over the couple of
weekends ago and I said yeah I saw you
go he goes oh she looks so hot you know
I mean and I showed him a picture of her
not a video it went off her he said to
me do you know what right you've upset
me oh the next day he was talking about
it I couldn't sleep all the next day she
went from like a sexy eight-year-old to
like a size 20 well and he couldn't
believe that it's the same person I said
I look a lot better in your eyes now
didn't I but I never had no problem with
him looking at other women because I
know that we're coming to our racing
that was your crush back then that's why
I was happy to show him that women let
themselves go they've always got so much
to talk about the men but when they get
to a certain age they let themselves go
on they still expect to get the same men
yep where's nine times out they don't
keep up they don't keep up the energy
they don't keep it up fake it